[MUSIC PLAYING]
LIAM MAXWELL: Great.
Thanks very much.
Thank you very much for coming.
I'm Liam Maxwell.
I'm the national
technology adviser
for the British government.
One of the things we
have talked about a lot,
and this morning was
really strong about culture
and the use of Open as culture
and how you deliver change.
And so what I'm
going to talk about
is how we delivered change
within a large organization
using Open as the dynamic.
Now, it is one of
those things that you
get a load of neologisms
in government,
so people suddenly start
thinking up new words which
become the word of the year.
I sensed on Wednesday,
really, people
were talking a lot
about lift and shift.
And I think one of the things
that we found when we started
in government was people started
talking about Agile as a thing.
And I'm here to say, be
careful about those neologisms
and how they're used, because
if you introduce a concept
like "Agile is a good
thing" into government,
people start building huge
things out of agileness,
and people start building
infrastructure in an agile way.
And I remember
once finding myself
in a presentation where somebody
described their approach to it
and their approach to change
is agilution, which is Agile
but done at their own pace.
It was strange, because it
didn't actually understand
what Agile, TM, really means.
So part of this is about talking
about the culture of what
we do.
And really at the
bottom is what you
find when you start moving
and changing an organization,
and how we used Open
as a dynamic for that.
So using Open to [INAUDIBLE].
So imagine, if you
will, that you've
discovered yourself
unexpectedly winning an election
and starting to
run a government.
What do you do at
that point, when
you start to look
around you and how you
can change what you're doing?
So our challenge was this.
In 2009, government IT cost
16 billion pounds in the UK.
Often I've found people say it's
quite worrying when you go over
about a million pounds.
It's quite difficult to
imagine what that money is.
16 billion is quite
a lot of money.
So there's 1% of our
economy was spent
on the administrative
functioning of technology
in government.
A lot of money.
And my minister had a
particularly interesting way
of describing that.
It wasn't good.
It didn't work for people.
And we didn't do the
most important things.
When you find yourself
in a new place,
you have to map where
you are, and you
have to measure where you are.
Unless you can work out
where you are qualitatively,
where in the cycle you
are, what you are using,
you won't be able to find
out how to play the game,
how to be in the chess board.
Simon Wardley's here.
He's doing a talk about
much more of this later.
But we used these techniques
to identify where we were.
The other thing is
measure where you are.
Now, who here thinks
the government is big?
The British-- think about it.
The British government.
Would you say it was a big
organization, 400,000 people,
lots of things,
aircraft carriers?
We have huge buildings.
Government itself, it
turns out, isn't very big.
The compute load to run a
government isn't enormous.
Government itself is, in fact,
not large in compute terms.
It's hell of a complex.
But it's not large.
And so we use some tools.
Just using transparency
of data helped
to identify what we
were doing and also
how much we were doing.
So the initial change, we
had to bring in controls.
We brought in the process
of spend controls.
And those spend controls
helped us identify
whether the people were
building things that we really
needed at that point.
Think about it.
2011, we were still at the
end of a financial crisis.
It was very important that we
only started building things
that we needed to use that
we hadn't built elsewhere.
And that meant you had to have
a view over the whole system,
over the whole ecosystem
within a government,
to check why you were building
one thing in one place
and one thing in another.
Now, if you look at
how technology grows,
you'll see that it starts
from things that are very new,
and they move through from
ubiquity through transition
through to a common or
a commodity service.
Now, we realized
that as a government,
this speed of transition of
technology is much, much faster
than we could react to.
So our game was not about
being a part of that cycle.
Our game was trying
to identify how
we worked within that cycle.
The problem was,
we had done this.
All of the things that we
were using were special.
Everything that we made,
everything we created,
everything that had been built
for us was special, and very
much special to each
department, and sometimes
special within a department, to
a particular business process.
Now, that's a
problem about the way
that governments spend money.
This is how the business
case process works.
You get a business case through
to run an immigration system
at a different time when you
get a business process through
to run a visa system.
But when you sit down and
think about it, the visa
system and the
immigration system
all use very similar components.
We just hadn't
identified it, and had
just gone and bought,
and gone and bought,
and gone and bought.
In many ways, we were procuring
our way out of trouble,
or so we thought.
But in fact, we were
digging a deeper hole,
because what we'd done is
we then locked everything
into a series of strong
system integrator contracts,
which meant that we couldn't
break out of the chain
and cause the change we needed,
because we had contractually
agreed to do things
in one particular way.
The things that we had
decided in 2008 to do
were going to be
valid until 2017.
Now, that's an
enormous, enormous jump
for an organization to take.
You've really got to
know that nothing's
going to change
during that period
if you're going to make
money in that space
and run an efficient service.
So first thing, we had
to change our shape.
Governments are built like this.
You have the Department of
International Development,
the Department of Agriculture,
the Department of Transport,
the Ministry of Education.
They're all separate entities.
And all of them,
for years, have been
running as separate
entities, and they
haven't been using this.
They haven't been using
any form of approach
to platform or
commonality, mostly
because they didn't know what
the other departments were
doing.
Just the simple act of
centralizing and opening data
enabled us to see how much
and how many things we
were doing that were common.
We also found there were
four main obstacles.
Now, I refer to this as
the square of despair,
because if you take over
a large organization,
one of the problems you're
going to find straightaway
is these four
things will get you.
OK, now, the most pernicious
of these I'll save for last.
But, capability.
We had to find
modern technologists
to come and work
with us, and that
meant we needed to offer people
great opportunities to come
and work in a government.
And many times, working
for the government
doesn't appear to be
an attractive thing.
I've got lots of friends
who do very boring jobs
and get paid lots of
money for doing that.
I offer completely
the opposite of that.
In government, you
have the opportunity
to change your government,
change what your nation does,
but we never pay government
at the same rate.
And part of that is
because it is a sort
of trade-off at that point.
The experience
that you will gain
in three years in
government is like 10 years
in another organization, because
if you know what you're doing,
your capacity and your
capability to change things
is immense.
And that's what attracted
200 great technology leaders
to come back and
work in government.
Next thing is security.
We were still
running our security
with a view to being in
the Cold War, really.
We had officials who were
working on social impact bonds
and charities under the
same security restrictions
as people working in an
intelligence organization.
So we had to move.
Most of government and the
delivery of public services,
97% of a government and the
is able to run at the same
level of security as a Skadden
or a Pricewaterhouse
or a Deloitte.
It's a great professional
services firm.
So we needed to
run at that rate,
and that meant we had to review
all of our security settings
and introduce one
common security layer
called Official,
at which everything
can work that is not
national security-related.
That also meant that we stopped
spending huge amounts of money
securing and locking down
people that needed to be open,
and we could spend the money
on the secure areas properly.
Then there's procurement.
Now, procurement is very
difficult sometimes to break,
because it's the thing
that's always there.
It's the thing which all
governments always run with.
All large organizations have
issues with procurement.
And we had to make
sure that we could
start procuring not
just from big companies,
but from the best companies.
And a little bit later I'll
explain how we did that.
But the best was what
we were looking for,
not the biggest,
not the people that
could spend 60,000 pounds as
if it were the drop of a hat
to fill in a procurement form
and run a bid team for three
months.
We needed to be
able to run things
where we could buy from the
best in the market, the most
innovative.
And many times, what we
were doing in procurement
was putting those people off.
And then legacy, the
most pernicious of all.
You can't do that,
because it's legacy.
You can't change that,
because if you change it,
you'll break it.
There will be riots
in the streets.
I had that said to
me several times.
We created a way of
moving legacy away.
It's called the Crown
Hosting Service.
What we do is we move
our legacy systems
into a special hosted
service which we run.
It's a zombie insurance
fund in the end.
It allows you to put stuff in.
The legacy can be looked after.
It can all be helped to stay
there whilst you can then
focus on the future.
And your future is about
building things in the cloud.
Now, culturally,
different organizations
do things different ways.
I'm not saying
that's the way that
would work immediately
for you, but believe me,
that works for us.
The creation of our own Hotel
California for government
IT has meant that we can put
stuff in, you can put it in,
we'll run it, it's nice, it
will always be looked after.
You just can never check it out.
So we found that technology was
moving faster than government.
We had to be free to keep up.
We had to change
shape, as I said.
So keep that in mind.
How do you introduce platforms?
How do you introduce common
services to an organization
that is a large organization
full of tremendously
gifted professional
people, but who have always
been working in silos?
So, the changes we made.
First, we had to say
what good looked like.
So we wrote down what
good looked like.
We literally wrote
a manual for CTOs,
which we then changed into the
technology code of practice.
And this was agreed by everybody
who was a technology leader.
So we convened everybody,
made sure everyone
agreed what good looked like.
We then agreed some
design principles,
because if you're designing
services for citizens,
we want to have a
common approach.
A citizen does not
look at the government
and think, actually,
that's really interesting,
it's 24 different departments.
A citizen looks at the
government and goes,
it's the government.
It's one thing.
So if you're going to have a
common approach to how you deal
with citizens, you need to
have common design principles,
again, which are agreed
and which are shared.
One of the things
we did to make sure
that we could work
properly is we realized
we were going to be using
the internet quite a lot,
so we needed to
have open standards.
And one of the most difficult
open standards we had to use
was how do you
explain to a citizen
that they need to,
at some points,
have a document which they need
to fill in or change or modify?
We had to do that in a way
that didn't require people
to sign in and use one
particular piece of software.
So we defined what an
open document format
should be for the government.
There was enormous
amount of peer review.
We did the same
consultation process
as you would do for
opening a new airport
to make sure we could do that.
But that brought
in the capability
to have common open standards.
And again, just culturally,
this held people's views
that open standards
are important.
We cut out a lot of friction.
So that was the
organization chart
that I had when I started.
If any of you can work
out how to do this bit,
I never got there.
I never worked out
that bit on the right,
because it was just too complex.
So we changed that.
We introduced this.
This is our organization.
This is our primary motivation.
Our primary organizing
thing was a browser.
And if you use a browser, these
things become really simple.
You can identify where you
have common services that you
all share.
You can identify where you
have common specific things
like ERP, which just should
be done in a similar way.
And then it allows you to create
new, great, digital services,
allows you to create the
mission IT, the internal IT
to work with people,
taking away and abstracting
all of that gumpf which
is the infrastructure.
And using the cloud for
that, and declaring the cloud
as the primary place for
that is the main change
within that space.
And we needed to work with
lots of innovative companies.
So we changed the way
that we worked with people
in our marketplace.
We created a new tech
sector called GovTech.
And this GovTech
sector was about,
how do we bring people in
to work with the government
and make it easy for them
to work with the government?
Not make it easy for
government to work with them.
It's a really
important difference.
And we grew a huge
number of jobs.
We drew a huge number
of innovations.
But what happened was this meant
that our tech cost less and was
better because we were going
to companies that specialized
in particular components, rather
than going to one big company
and saying, please take it
all away from me and do it.
So that's 1.6 billion sales.
55-- 55.
I've got a new number.
It was 54.
55% of that is
small-medium enterprises.
So it's a way of government
helping build the innovation
and helping grow the businesses.
And so we now feel the UK is
a center of digital excellence
in government.
We're the number one
digital government according
to the United Nations, and
we have started our move
because what we've done
is instead of treating
our technology on the
left of that diagram,
we're now doing so much
more of it on the right.
We're doing so much more using
the capability of common tools
so that you can focus
on the things that
are important in
government, which
is building great services
for your citizens.
Now, a lot of this
is down to the use
of one four-letter word, Open.
Open helped us change this.
Open was our disruptor.
If you need to
construct a narrative
to change your
government, Open works.
So four things we
did that were open.
One, open markets.
As you'll see, we had a
small number of providers.
We now have lots of providers.
We have an open market which
people will come and invest in,
and people will grow their
businesses in in the UK.
We committed to using the cloud.
We committed to using the
internet to run our government.
And by doing that, that meant
that we had to-- because it's
a common service, it's
a common resource,
we have to commit to
using open standards.
We have to be very
adult about the fact
that we want to use open
standards across the whole
of the government.
So if you are a police force,
or you are an ambulance service,
or you're a fire
and rescue service,
you should be getting
your updates and your data
about incidents in a common
format, in a common way,
according to common standards,
so you can all work together.
It actually starts to get
really important at that point
that people can understand
what's going on.
And that was one
of the main lessons
we learned about the bombings--
the 7/7 bombings, was that
all of our emergency services
had to work together,
clearly, effectively.
And open standards
are right at the core
not of that, but across the
whole approach to what we
do as government, so that we can
use the resources effectively.
We committed to open data.
You'll know that Tim Berners-Lee
and Nigel Shadbolt established
the Open Data Institute.
And we started to publish
data about what we were doing,
not just about spending.
I actually passed
a legislation that
meant that local
authorities would
publish all of their
spending over 500 pounds.
We then started
introducing new tools
to help people change their
behavior using open data.
One of the most
successful things
we did in a local government
was we published the energy
usage of our buildings.
By publishing the energy
usage of the buildings
then meant that everyone
could see which building
was leaving the lights on.
And actually, by putting the
email address of the person
responsible for the
building, we managed
to save 25% of our energy
spend without actually
talking to anybody.
It just happened, because
people wrote in and went,
you've left the lights on.
And as soon as that
happened, the officials
changed the behavior.
It was wonderful.
It was a really good way
of making data work for us
and use open data.
But also, the open data that we
publish around our government
helps now power big
companies I don't
know if you saw on stage during
that keynote a guy called
Herman Narula from Improbable.
But Improbable
runs on state data.
The city they've constructed
is constructed out
of the open data that we
provide as a government.
We have, in our hands, an
enormous amount of the data
that we can provide and run
and help our economy with,
and yet we didn't make
it open in the past.
We can really help that.
And then finally, open source.
I'll talk a little bit more
about why open source is
so important to us, but open
source was one of those four
that drove the change of
what we did about government.
And it's the heart of what
other governments are doing.
If you look at those
four governments,
you'll notice that they
are similar to us in a way.
We picked to work with these.
We formed a group called
the D5, because we
were all at the similar
stages of our growth.
The Korean government
on the bottom right
started to build a digital
marketplace rather like our G
Cloud, like our
digital marketplace,
about four years before
we did, because they
identified that they needed
to get that innovation in.
The Estonian government,
possibly-- and everybody
always cites the Estonians as
a great digital government--
use a component called the
X-Road, which they've open
sourced, which is
a component which
allows government services
to work together so that you
can join up.
It's a core part of one of
their great signature policies,
which is called Once Only.
Once you've told the government
who you are and where you live,
the government should never
be required to ask you again.
That's wonderfully simple.
But if you imagine
the mess that you
get when you start
a government, it's
quite difficult to get there.
But that's where you go.
That's what they've got.
New Zealand has
done a lot of work.
They did great pioneering
work on identity with RealMe.
And also, I remember first time
I walked into a New Zealand
government office and there
were storyboards and profiles
and people working in a
proper way, proper agile way,
on new developments.
And we realized that New
Zealand was very like the UK
in where we were in our
journey, and as was Israel.
And you'll notice that
gov.il, on the top left,
they've taken off the
picture these days,
but gov.il and the New
Zealand government site
looks rather like
gov.uk, and there's
a reason for that,
because to a large part,
they are the same thing.
So we created the same thing.
We created the government of the
internet, a government that's
started using the
internet properly
and effectively to
deliver its services.
Let's just have a think
about what's next.
We used Open to unlock change.
We used Open to create
competition to help us grow.
Competition was the
thing that drove it.
It wasn't about, say,
we didn't stand up
and say, everything
must be open source.
What we did was we created
the conditions for success
for people that worked
using open standards.
And in doing so, open
source became more and more
a component of our government.
In 2011, I was sat down by a
security analyst who read out
why you should not use open
source software to me, in front
of his team, so
that he felt that he
had delivered the lesson to me.
It was one of those
things that I always
remember, because he's
not saying that now.
It's really obvious that
that was a huge [INAUDIBLE].
But it wasn't that we'd said,
we will now back open source.
It was we said we
will back competition.
We will back openness.
And also, the high level
of small-medium business
engagement is there because
we back competition,
that we back the ability
for a small company
to do exactly the same
work as a large company,
and possibly at a lower rate.
Some of the times, when
we started to get going--
famously there was
an occasion when
a hosting service was being
sold by a company for 5
million pounds.
We got exactly the
same thing for 54,000.
Two factors, two
factors of difference,
two orders of
magnitude difference.
And so we moved from
one to the other.
We moved from silos.
We introduced common
platform services.
And those common
platform services
allowed us to rationalize
what we were doing
and also allowed us to
share what people are doing.
And services like gov UK verify
and gov UK pay and gov UK
notify are platform
services that
enable you to deliver common
functionality to parts
of government.
Think for a second about Notify.
So Notify, which is run by one
of my heroes in government,
a guy called Pete Hurley,
Notify shows you where
and tells you when your tools--
your passport, your
driving license--
when it is coming back.
Now, we get half a billion
telephone calls a year.
25% of them were to
say, I don't know where
something is on the internet.
Can you help?
In your website,
how do I find it?
So we made a website
that worked for the user,
and it generated savings.
Those savings, if
you think about it,
were people not calling.
And if you're getting half
a billion telephone calls
at 12 pounds a call, there's
a lot of money to save.
25% of those were people
saying, where's my thing?
So by introducing a
notification service,
you can help people find out
where their services are,
find out where their passport,
their driving license,
or their application
for a license is.
And people can then not
call in, and we save money.
And all of these things are
sensible, straightforward
approaches to government which
we've started to bring in.
But I wanted to, as we talk
about Open and open source,
just have a think about
the picture of governments.
There's lots of people
from different countries
in this room, and you
all have a government.
On the right hand side there is
the Norwegian driving license
agency, or the Norwegian
Ministry of Transport.
And they issue driving
licenses to Norwegians.
They ask people
for their identity.
They ask them for a photograph.
They record it.
They keep it in a database.
It's really strange,
because the British DVLA
do exactly the same thing.
So why are we all trying to
do exactly the same thing
differently?
In America, there are 50 states.
Each state issues
a driving license.
They do exactly the
same thing, but issuing
a driving license
in the UK is just
a weird jurisdictional thing.
We have a monopoly market.
We don't compete.
It may be good
news, but we're not
going to set up a driver
license service in Norway,
because they've already
got one, and they've
got a monopoly on that market.
But we do the same thing.
And in compute terms, we're
doing exactly the same thing
as we go through this.
So this leads us to
think, as we learned
by sharing the code of gov
UK, that actually, there's
an opportunity to
share a lot more
between different governments,
and that by sharing
not just our code,
but our tooling
and also the methodology
that we brought in,
we can go and work and help
other governments to get over
all the barriers that
we started to face,
but in addition, and
one of the things
we learned by sharing
with other governments,
is that we get a hell of a lot
back in terms of knowledge,
capability, and
help, because they've
thought about these things in
a completely different way.
So if you think about how
you would run and build
a government, and
if you had turned up
and found yourself needing to
work with a new government,
one of the things you need to
do is work with open source
properly.
Those components of open
data and open standards
play into this because as
you build your new services,
and as you build your new
government in the cloud,
open source can help.
Let me just talk you through
this rather busy slide.
Lots of people worry about
platform as a service,
and worry about the
infrastructure underneath.
And remember, most of
IT for the last 20 years
has been about people building
great big infrastructures
that they own and they can
go and polish every Tuesday
when they need to.
And they feel massively
secure because they
can see the servers.
When I first
started in politics,
I walked into the local
government office, the data
room of my local government,
and there were 130 servers
and 130 cathode ray tubes.
And it was 2007.
It was like going
back in time then.
Now, in three years,
we had made it
a rule within the authority--
2010, we bought our
last application server.
We wrote in the Constitution
that the council would never
buy another application server.
In my world, if I
ran the world, it
would be a criminal offense
to go and buy an email server.
All of those things,
they're common.
And if you move on to having
an abstractive platform
as a service approach, it
means that your platform
and your common infrastructure
should be there.
We shouldn't talk about CIOs.
I mean, a CIO to me is a
chief infrastructure officer.
It's the person that
runs all of that stuff
so that you can build
great things on top of it.
So once you've got
the PaaS, then you
move on to your registers.
Now, as a government, one
of the glorious things
we have is huge numbers.
Imagine 300 years of
building departments.
Can you imagine how many
different data sets we have?
We have huge numbers of
data sets all the way
across every department.
The personnel data sets, as we
now build our digital economy
bill, we have to create
a register of where
we store data for people.
We also need to create
registers of information.
We found that we had
15 different lists
of, and databases of, countries.
Think about it.
Even that most basic thing,
the names of another country,
there were 15,
because everyone had
an argument about whether
something was called
the republic of this or that.
And ultimately, if we're
going to work as a government,
we have to recognize there
must be a list of countries.
There must be a list
of universities.
There must be a list of schools.
If we only have one
list, the efficiency
of running a government
becomes much more effective,
but also things work more
effectively for people.
We don't want to
get to the stage
where you send somebody
to the wrong school,
or you put people, or
pay the wrong university.
And that can happen if
you have different lists.
So we want to make
sure that works,
and we have a program of
registers which is run by a guy
called Paul Downey,
who is putting together
this way of consolidating our
registers together so that you
have a common approach
and a common set,
a single canonical source,
persistent canonical source
of data with provenance
and integrity.
That allows you to build a
modern, functioning state.
And then also open
source components,
because we are
building components
and we are building
our work in components.
We can share those components
with other organizations.
They can become better.
And therefore, when we start
to build a new service,
we don't have to build
everything from scratch.
We can go and use the components
that people have made before.
When they were building
the prison booking service,
it was amazing because
people were saying,
well, you know, the internet
solved booking years ago.
Just work out the functionality
around this particular use
case of doing it in prisons.
And so by building
open source components
with other
governments, we believe
that we will move to a
much smoother and much more
effective way of building
services that actually
meet the needs of the users.
And by applying
that discipline, it
means that you can then
focus on building services
that work for users,
that meet user needs.
And that means you have to
create multidisciplinary teams
where the policy people
and the delivery people
are in the same space, which
means that as policy changes,
you can change the
delivery mechanism.
But also, and more importantly,
as the data changes,
you can then make
the policy change.
And you can start to
create a government that
not only works for
its citizens, but is
relevant for its citizens.
And that relies on
excellent user research.
It relies on using design
as your core methodology,
as the core thing.
The design of the
services are so important.
And it also means
being big enough
to work out that you need
to use continuous, iterative
approaches that mean you
change as your people change.
Remember, the system that we
built in 2008 that was there
to work forever,
we've probably paid
for it twice in all
the change control
requests we had to bring in.
This gets out of that
massive cost burden.
It reduces the risk, and it
delivers government services
that work for people.
And so this is the mantra.
Don't do it all yourself.
You can't.
Work with other people.
As governments, we can work
with other governments.
We don't compete.
And if we start to focus on
what really works for citizens
is the design and delivery
of great services,
and that massively reduces
the size, the scale,
and the cost of the tech
that runs behind it.
We remove the friction,
because if you remove friction
from services, things
work more effectively.
More people will use them.
More people will go to
use the digital service,
and we will start to enable
the policy aim we started with,
which was digital by default,
digital services that are so
good people prefer to use them.
And so that's how we're
going to make sure
the government
keeps moving fast.
And GovTech is a growth market.
If you want to work and
interact with government,
and you have components
for government,
the digital marketplace,
the address of which
is at the bottom
left, that's where
you can apply to
deliver your services
to the British government.
And we want new,
innovative services
that help us deliver better
services for our citizens.
And because of the
way we've done this,
and because of the
way we've built this,
we now know we can do it.
And those numbers
should help you
realize that we're
serious about this,
that if we're going
to get more than half
of our business coming in on
new tech from small businesses,
that's going to change
not only the way
the British government
works, but also it's
going to be a great
magnet for new tech
to come into our country.
So thank you very
much for listening.
I'm open to questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]